you propose in front of a crowd mm-hmm
which feel like at the Ryman yeah why'd
you want to do it like there why'd you
want in front of a crowd like that
because it's such a part of both of our
lives music and playing concerts and the
Ryman was also one of our first dates
when she came to this match for the
first time so it kind of was just you
know and I'm busy yeah back in October
John popped the question to his fiancee
summer and with his wedding just around
the corner the country star is making
sure two key elements are at the venue
standing by actually bringing three
busloads of alcohol too just in case
are you really we're not you know come
on the bus drinking seems to be a thing
with John Kander nose man
it was a lot of trading songs on the
elderly oh yeah sorry medication get no
well sonically like how do you describe
the album I hear a lot of my influences
on heartache medication it's a great
just let put it in let it play takes you
on my kind of musical rollercoaster
journey and there's just a lot of great
lyrics and melodies and songs in there
that's all kind of meant to make this
whole record just kind of be a big
presence right in your car stereo or
your house stereo wherever you listen to
me
[Music]
his music is really resonated with
Canadians during our interview we
presented him with two plaques one for
his number-one single at Canadian
country radio and a gold certified
single for heartache medication so
what's the key to his success people
skills just be a nice guy will tell you
that's probably most important okay
don't worry you bet I gotta back it up
though they knew like math sucks so you
know I say if you can rock you'd be able
to roll but if you can roll you better
be able to rock that makes sense yes I
think so
you